so Dave tell us a little bit about these
new Nexus phones he introduced today
yeah so today's the first time we've
launched two Nexus phones simultaneously
so we're pretty excited we first have
the Nexus 6p which is a 5.7 inch
all-metal premium device and it's
starting at $499 and then a return of
the fan-favorite the Nexus 5x so it's
replacing the original Nexus 5 which is
one of our most loved phones starting at
$379 both phones have amazing cameras
especially for indoor photography you
know we spent over on average 20 hours a
day indoors so we figured maybe make the
camera good for indoor photography we
also got amazing displays on the devices
and also what we think is the fastest
fingerprint sensor on the market today
so with this device we placed a
fingerprint right in the back which is
the most natural place to put it because
where you hold the device one touch and
the phone will just wake up and unlock
like that so it's super fast
so both these phones are unlocked
they're a little more expensive but you
can use them on any network I feel like
the perpetual question around the Nexus
in Alaska again is who are these phones
for are these reference designs for
other manufacturers or they really are
is Google trying to go out and capture
the high-end corner of the Android
Marketplace I think it's a little bit of
everything in fact right so we started
first back at the software right we
create Android and so our latest version
Android 6.0 marshmallow is is rolling
out next week and so to create an you
know an actual mobile operating system
or platform you can't do it in the
abstract you actually to build hardware
that Hardware needs to be really good
you need to be carrying it around Damien
say yeah we're really perfecting the
software on it so first and foremost
that's how Nexus was born but then
second what we realize is we can also
showcase the very best hardware the very
best software hardware integration to
sort of inspire others to do their job
and then third we realized well people
really like these devices right and so
we have you know a really strong
following of these devices first of all
you know you have to a tech enthusiast
and sort of first adopters but then what
we've noticed is that what happens is
that those those sort of first adopters
and recommend their phone to their maybe
less technical families and friends and
so you get the second and third order
effect and so you know it's really a
combination of all the above so you've
worked closely with Huawei on the 6p and
with LG on the 5x I mean and you're
integrating hardware and software to
create that fast and polished experience
how do you spread it out how do you how
do you recreate that effect
the rest of the now very kind of
fractured Android world well so you know
when we build a software you know as
soon as we've got the phones ready and
we launch it we just open source the
code so we just make it available for
anybody to take you know another area
that we've improved in in terms of
hardware software integration is the
Android sensor hub so we've created this
separate discreet processor that allows
you to run sensor processing in a low
power efficient mode and so we're just
making that available to anybody who
wants to take it and use it in their own
devices so it's really about you know
building the technology and then trying
to spread it agon because it's what are
the interesting design decisions on
these phones is the fingerprint sensor
on the back right right tell us why you
did that okay and what kind of
accelerant that might be right Android
pay and other identity service lemon two
questions do you hold your phone like
this or do you hold your phone like this
so you hold your phone like don't worry
though that I might inadvertently
activate that so I've been using this
for several weeks it is life changing
like I have never intermittently
activated it and it's perfect it is so
fast it's it's it's awesome yeah I think
it's probably one of the strongest
features is actually the whole
fingerprint integration so not only can
I just unlock the phone an obvious thing
to do I can also then go into a store
and I can pay so all I have to do is
like tap the back of the phone wave the
phone on the payment terminal and I'm
done it's like super efficient super
smooth you can like get your hipster
like swipe in it's very cool and then
also we've integrated because a
fingerprint support is an Android 602
marshmallow we've integrated in and
we've developer API so now we have
integrations and like your banking
application or their commerce
applications even in the Google Play
Store when you want to purchase
something you can use your fingerprint
so it just makes a device much more
effective and seamless to use so
marshmallow as you said start shipping
next week but how quickly can you get it
to all those phones in Android world
right it's always been a kind of a
drawback to Android that you might have
a phone I could see marshmallow on my
Motorola find a year right says one
things we've been working hard on is
trying to accelerate how quick the
software gets out on other devices so
what you know we have different programs
that we're trying and we actually this
year we actually made the source code
available much more early - you mention
Motorola so they've had that code for
quite some time and so we're trying to
like seed it much where earlier in the
cycle you might have noticed we also
made a Developer Preview of M as we
called it before we own they unveiled an
a marshmallow
we made that available you know right
back in May at Google i/o we
over the summer so it allows hardware
manufacturers to get an early try it out
bring it up on their devices it allows
developers to get to it more quickly so
we're trying to like grease the wheel of
the ecosystem to get those and you
desert releases that more quickly so you
talked about sensor hub it does seem
today and lots of the things that you
debuted that computer Google's trying to
make computer science and machine
learning turning it into a competitive
advantage right a benefit for users one
of the one of the nice features you
showed or is is how apps can become
aware when you use them and present
themselves at that particular time of
day how deep of a competitive advantage
is that for Google visa vie some of the
other platforms that are out there yeah
I think like machine learning and deep
learning as it's known these days is is
one of the big strengths of Android if
you look at how Google Photos works like
for me it automatically can detect my my
my one-year else face and like if I
scroll back a dot in history it goes
back to the very first photo that was
taken like literally three seconds after
she was born it's just amazing had this
technology works
you know Google's very much a
cloud-based company so when we say we
were integrating software card or
actually really integrating hardware
software on the phone and the cloud we
would have all to be very seamless and
when you start thinking about computing
really you know where is it going next
so you know we think about contextual
computing and about sort of you know
technology getting smarter and getting
out of the way so for example this
morning when I parked my car and I got
out of the car and I have a little card
on my phone telling me where I parked my
car and that worked because the Android
sensor hubs running in the background
yeah it's running in low-power in the
background into tech and you the
activity and you I was in a car then a
new honest walking was like oh hey you
did a phase change there so then it
records the current location it's just
an example of like technology in the
background gets out of the way but it's
very helpful for you you know Google now
has lots of other features like it will
tell me when my Amazon parcel arrives in
my hives for example they will tell me
when a bill is up and jus I will tell me
my flight information and if it's late
and so we start integrating all of this
technology particularly when you're
connected to the cloud because the cloud
you know you've got these massive data
centers if you think about your phone's
basing a supercomputer node right when
you pull all that together we think that
you can get much more advanced for the
contextual
use cases and we think that's sort of
the future where this is going getting
smarter getting out of the way you talk
today a bit about google playing music
and then down it's the family
subscription $15 right right yep yeah so
to the Apple music user who's trial
subscription has expired yes but what's
the pitch for google music so I don't
work at Google Music directly but I'm
definitely a user of it the idea with
the family plan is you can have up to
six members of your family using this
we've made Google Play users run
everywhere right so everybody your phone
your tablets it was surprised they're
cross-platform Roza Android TV runs a
chromecast you didn't control from your
watch so just works everywhere and then
it's got an enormous music catalog
you've got like you know specific songs
and albums you can get and listen to in
the subscription or you can it has a
concierge service so like you know if
you feel like I'm in the mood for jazz
music or mellow indie you just choose
that and will select and curate music
for you it's a really nice experience so
I have to ask you Google as it has been
for the past few years has been under
tremendous scrutiny from regulators in
Europe in the US around its
administration of Android how much does
that constrain the innovation on Android
and what how you guys think about tying
apps into the platform pushing them out
to users what customers can do with apps
to uninstall if they want yeah I mean
when we think about Android first and
foremost it's an open source platform so
we create the code and then we make it
available and anyone can take it and
then from there there's a set of Google
applications one of the things that
we've done on the new Nexus device is
this is something I you know we've been
working on for quite a while is a new
service that basically means that when
you're setting up the phone we try to
move as many of the non-essential
applications to get installed post set
up the result is you can then uninstall
those applications just like any other
app and that's sort of the approach that
we've been we've been taking and you
know from there you know people ship
Android devices with and they they
bundled whatever services they want on
top of that it's a it's an open market
can they can add what they need great
well why don't you conclude by telling
us when and where we can buy these new
Nexus devices right so so we are making
these available on the new online Google
store you can pre-order them today
either the 6p or the 5x that I love my
children equally and they will start
shipping them out
in October and these are amazing devices
we think people are gonna love them
Dave Burke thank you very much sir thank
you